[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: Here's
the agenda for today.
As usual, a bunch of
announcements in red.
Assignment 4 was graded.
There will be comments showing
up online on Stellar soon
on any of you who didn't get
a near-perfect score on it.
And I'll also be going over a
little bit of it in a moment.
And then once we do
that, we're going
to talk about navigation--
how we know where we are,
and how to get from here
to someplace else, which
is much more awesome than it
sounds at first, as you will
see.
OK.
So quick review.
So what was the key point?
Why did I assign the Haxby 2001
article for you guys to read?
It presents this
important challenge
to the functional specificity
of the face area and the place
area.
What was that challenge?
What was Haxby's key point?
Yes, Isabel.
AUDIENCE: Well, he
was just attacked--
it just has a preference
for rectilinear
and not seeing if it's
actual scanning for.
It's not truly detecting
whether it's a face or not.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
He wasn't worrying about
rectilinearity so much back
then.
But his point was that
we shouldn't care just
about the overall magnitude
of response of a region.
Like, OK, it's nice
if the face area
responds like this to face,
but isn't like that to objects.
But even if it responds low and
the same to cars and chairs,
it might still have information
to enable you to distinguish
cars from chairs if the pattern
of response across boxes
in that region was stably
different for cars and chairs.
OK?
That's really key.
We'll go over it at
a few more points.
But that's essential, right?
A lot of the details that
I'm going to teach you
that go by in
class don't matter,
but I really want you guys
to understand the PPA.
And that's the nub of it.
OK?
So the idea is that
selective-- his claim
is that selective regions,
like the face area,
contain information about
non-preferred stimuli.
That is, like, non-faces
for the face area,
or non-places for
the place area.
And because they
contain information,
those regions don't care only
about their preferred category.
So why does Kanwisher
get off saying
the FFA is only about faces and
the PPA is only about places
if we can see information about
other things in those regions?
OK.
That's a really
important critique.
That's why we're
spending time on it.
OK?
OK.
Next, what kind
of empirical data
might be an answer
to Haxby's challenge?
I presented at least
three different kinds
of data that can address this
and say, hey, wait a minute.
You know, you have a point,
but what kind of data
could speak to that
and respond to Haxby?
We didn't actually talk about
this explicitly in class,
but think about it.
Here's the claim he makes.
What might we say, right?
So that's empirically true.
Like, you look in the FFA.
Even in my own data, I
can distinguish chairs
from shoes a little
teeny bit in the FFA.
OK?
So that empirical claim is true.
Why might it
nonetheless be the case
that the face area is really
only about face recognition?
What other data have
you heard in here
that might make you think that?
Yes, Ben.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's the presence--
NANCY KANWISHER: Speak up.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
The presence of low-level
stimuli that are generally in
faces, but can also be sparse
on chairs and cars in context.
NANCY KANWISHER: Absolutely.
So yeah, put another
way, even if you
had a perfect coder for faces--
like take your best deep net
for face recognition, VGG face--
it can distinguish chairs
and shoes too, right?
The features that you
use to represent faces
will slightly discriminate
between other non-face objects.
So the fact that we can see
that information in itself
isn't strong evidence
that that region isn't
selective for face perception.
Absolutely.
What else?
Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: Like transcranial
magnetic stimulation?
When you stimulate
the epithelial
and you look at it
face it affects it,
but when you are like
looking at other objects,
the effect is no longer.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
And so what does
that tell you about--
OK, so there's
pattern information
in there about other
things beyond faces.
But?
Apparently it's not used, right?
Now with every bit of evidence,
you can always argue back.
People would say, well,
TMS, those effects are tiny.
Maybe there isn't and
we didn't have power
to detect it, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
But at least,
absolutely you're right.
TMS argues against them.
What else?
Or at least is a way to argue
against it-- and the Pitcher
paper that I assigned
and other papers
that we've talked about in
here provide some evidence
that actually, at least the
occipital face area really
is only causally involved
in face perception
even if there's information
in there about other things.
What else?
What other methods
can address this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That is
pretty new simulation,
and even when you're pressing
hand against your face,
you can perceive faces in it.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
So these are both
causal tests, right?
OK, there's
information in there.
But is it causally
used in behavior?
TMS suggests not.
The little bit of direct
intracranial stimulation data
that I showed you also suggests
the causal effects when you
stimulate that region are
specific to face perception,
again suggesting that
even if there's pattern
information in there,
it's not doing anything
important because
we can mess it up
and nothing happens to the
perception of things that
aren't faces.
Absolutely.
What else?
We talked about it very
briefly a few weeks ago.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you
remove the [INAUDIBLE],,
it just completely
makes a person
incapable of perceiving faces.
That is causing--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, but
the crucial way-- yes,
but the crucial way
to address Haxby
would be what further
aspect of that?
Yes.
And by the way, we don't
remove the area in humans,
but occasionally,
we find a human
who had a lesion there due to a
stroke and then we study them.
AUDIENCE: So they're still
able to do other categories.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
So all three lines of evidence
from studies of prosopagnosia,
electrical stimulation directly
on the brain, and TMS, all
can provide evidence
to various degrees.
Again, one can
quibble about each
of these particular studies.
But all of those suggests that
even though there's information
in the pattern,
Haxby's right-- there's
information in there about
other things that aren't faces.
The only causal effects when
you mess up with that region
are on faces, not
on other things.
That suggests that
pattern information
is what they sometimes say
in philosophical circles is
"epiphenomenal."
That is, it's just not related
to behavior and perception.
Make sense?
OK, moving along,
how can we then
use Haxby's method
to not just engage
in this little fight about the
FFA and how specific it is,
but to harness this method and
ask other interesting questions
from functional MRI data.
How can we use it to find out,
for example, does the place
area discriminate, say, beach
scenes from city scenes?
We want to know what's
represented in there.
How could we use this
method to find out?
Yes, Jimmy.
AUDIENCE: If I do what
Haxby kind of did, and try
the decoder, and see if
the decoder could decide
and differentiate between
the city and or like
an acre of shade.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
So we talked about
decoding methods
last time as a way to
use machine learning
to look at the
pattern of response
in a region of the brain, and
train the decoder so it knows
what the response looks like
during viewing of beach scenes,
train it so it knows what
the response in that region
looks like when you're
looking at city scenes,
and then take a new
pattern, and say,
is this more like
the beach pattern
or is it more like
the city pattern?
And that's how you could
decode from that region.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That doesn't tell as
much, in the sense that it's
not telling you--
I mean, we know that there
is residue of information
nevertheless, and
that this community
can be varied on any region
considered at any time, always.
NANCY KANWISHER: We have
a true nihilist here.
No, it's a good question.
It's not the case that you can
discriminate anything based
on any region of the brain.
So there are some constraints.
There are some
things you can find
in some places and other things
you can find in other places.
And they're not uniformly
distributed over the brain.
However, the fact we
just-- the point I just
made about yes, there's
discriminative information
in the face area about non-faces
but maybe it's not used,
should raise a huge caveat
about this whole method.
How do we ever know?
We see some discriminative
information.
How do we know
whether it's actually
used by the brain,
part of the brain's
own code for information, or
just epiphenomenal garbage
that's a byproduct
of something else?
It's a really important question
about all of pattern analysis.
We do it anyway
because we're beggars.
We can't be choosers in terms
of methods with human cognitive
neuroscience.
And we want to know
desperately what's
represented in each region.
So we do this.
But whenever you
see these lovely,
"I can decode x from y," things,
you should always be wondering.
Who knows if that fact
that you, the scientist,
can decode it from
that region means
the brain itself is reading that
information out of that region?
Big, important question.
All right, put another way--
so Jimmy mentioned just
decoding in general
and that's absolutely right.
But to directly harness
the Haxby version of this,
what would we do?
First, we would functionally
localize the PPA
by scanning them, looking
at scenes and objects,
find that region
in each subject.
Then we would collect
the pattern of response
across voxels in the
PPA while subjects were
looking at, say, beach scenes.
And so if this is the
PPA, this is the pattern
of response across voxels
in that region when they're
looking at beach scenes--
fake data, obviously,
just to give you the idea.
So we would split the data
in half, even runs, odd runs.
That would be like even runs.
Then we get another
pattern for odd runs.
And then we get another
pattern for when they're
looking at city
scenes with even runs,
and another pattern
when they're looking
at city scenes in odd runs.
So then, once we have
those four patterns,
what is the key prediction
if using Haxby's correlation
method?
What is the key prediction if
the PPA, if pattern of response
in the PPA, can discriminate
beach scenes from city scenes?
What should we see
from these patterns?
What's the key prediction?
Claire.
Key prediction-- you have
these four patterns in the PPA,
and now you want to know is
there information in there
that enables you to discriminate
beach scenes from city scenes?
AUDIENCE: Is that like
beach even and beach
odd are more similar than
beach even and city even?
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
Right.
It sounds all complicated and
it's easy to get confused.
But the nub of the
idea is really simple.
It just says, look, the
beach patterns are stable.
We do beach a few times, we get
the same pattern, more or less.
We do city, we get
a different pattern.
And we keep doing city, we get
the same pattern more or less.
And the beach pattern and the
city pattern are different.
So that's the nub of the idea.
And so you can implement it with
decoding methods or the Haxby
versions, just to ask whether
the correlation between two
beach patterns-- beach
even, beach odd--
is more similar than the pattern
between one of the beaches
and one of the cities.
Just asking, are they stably
similar within a category
and stably different
from another category?
Does that make sense?
This is just a variant of this
thing I showed you guys before.
We just harnessed this to
ask whether that region can
discriminate.
OK, and I just said all of this.
If you still feel
shaky on this, there's
a few things you can do.
A version of my little
lecture on this method
is here at my website.
You can look at that.
It's just like six
minutes and it's basically
what I did before.
But if you want to go over
it again, there it is.
You can reread the Haxby paper,
which I know is not super easy,
but it's actually
nicely written.
And if you read it carefully,
it explains the method
pretty clearly.
You can talk to me or a TA.
And we'll get back
to this question
of whether we should
do a whole MATLAB based
problem set on this.
OK, let's move on and
talk about navigation.
This is a Monarch butterfly.
It weighs about half a gram.
And yet, each fall
the Monarch migrates
over 2,000 miles from the USA
and Canada down to Mexico.
In fact, a single Monarch
flies 50 miles in a single day.
It's pretty amazing for
this tiny, little, beautiful
delicate thing.
Even more amazing-- it flies
to a very specific forest
in Mexico that's just
a few acres in size.
And it arrives at that
particular forest.
Now, that's already
amazing, but here's
the part that is just totally
mind blowing and that is--
and it flies back
north in the spring--
and that is that this whole
cycle takes four generations
to complete.
And that means that the Monarch
that starts up in Canada
and flies down to that
forest in Mexico--
one Monarch does that--
is the great-great-grandkid
of his ancestor
that last went on that route.
Put that in your
head and smoke it.
That's pretty amazing.
Consider the female
loggerhead turtle.
She hatches at a beach,
and goes out in the sea,
and swims around in
the sea for 20 years
before she comes back 20
years later for the first time
to the beach that
she hatched at.
Now, it's pretty amazing, but
some mothers miss by 20 miles.
They go to the wrong
island or the wrong beach
on the same island.
And so you might think,
OK, it's pretty good.
It's not amazing.
But here's the thing--
the wrong beach
that those mothers
go to is the exactly right beach
had the Earth's magnetic field
not shifted slightly
over those 20 years.
They're exactly
precise, but they just
don't compensate for the shift
in the Earth's magnetic field.
Here's a bat.
This bat maintains
its sense of direction
even while it flies 30 to
50 miles in a single night
in the dark catching food.
And it maintains its
sense of direction
even though it's flying around
in all different orientations
in three dimensions, and
even as it flips over
and lands to perch on
the surface of a cave.
It doesn't get confused
by being upside down.
This is Cataglyphis,
the Tunisian desert ant.
These guys are amazing.
They crawl around on the
surface of the Tunisian desert
where it's 140 degrees
in the daytime,
and they have to crawl around
up there to forage for food.
And then because it's so damn
hot, as soon as they find food,
they zoom back to their
nest and go down in the nest
where it's cooler.
So here is a track
of Cataglyphis
starting at point
A and foraging.
He's meandering around
looking for food going along
this whole crazy
path to point B.
And then if he finds
food at point B,
boom-- straight line
back exactly to the nest.
Now we might ask,
how does Cataglyphis
keep track as he's doing all
this stuff of where his heading
is back to his nest?
The first thing
you might think of
is things like
what it looks like.
Maybe there are landmarks,
maybe there are odors.
But no, he doesn't use
any of those things.
And we know that because when
scientists who have set up
this measurement device capture
Cataglyphis after he goes out
on this tortuous path and
finds the feeding station,
they capture him and move them
across the desert-- on which
they've drawn all these grid
lines for the convenience
of their experiment-- and
they release them here.
And what does Cataglyphis do?
He goes on the exactly
correct vector--
no landmarks, no relevant
odors, and yet he's
obviously encoded the exact
vector of how to get home.
Think about what that
entails and what's involved.
AUDIENCE: The same vector
with respect to north?
NANCY KANWISHER:
With respect to--
yes, well, with respect to
absolute external direction,
absolutely.
So that's what I just said.
So these feats of animal
navigation are amazing.
And animals have evolved ways
to solve all these problems
unique to their environment.
They've evolved these
abilities because they really
have to be able to find
food, and mates, and shelter.
And this is not just esoterica
in the natural world.
MIT students, too,
need to be able to find
food, and mates, and shelter.
So what is navigation, anyway?
And what does it entail?
Well, I'll argue over
the next two lectures
that there are two fundamental
questions that organisms
need to solve to be
able to navigate.
First one is, where am I?
And the second one is, how do I
get from here to there, A to B,
wherever there is
that you need to get?
So we'll unpack this.
There are many different
facets of each.
But so for example,
if you see this image,
you immediately
know where you are,
and you also know where
to go if, for example, it
starts raining.
You might rush into lobby
7, or if you're hungry,
you might turn around and go
back to the Student Center.
Same deal here--
if you see this,
then you know where you
are and where you would
go to get to various things.
Now, these judgments rely
on the specific knowledge
you guys have of those
particular places.
You recognize that
exact place, and you
have some kind of
map in your head
that we'll talk more
about in a moment, that
tells you where everything
else is with respect to it.
But even if you're in a
place you don't know at all
you can still extract
some information.
So suppose you miraculously
found yourself-- boom-- here.
I wouldn't mind,
actually, but that's not
in the cards for a while.
So you're here.
Even if you've just
hiked around the corner,
if you've never seen
this place before,
you have some kind of idea of
what sort of place this is.
Where would you pitch your tent?
Where might you try to go
to get out of this valley?
If it was me, I wouldn't.
I have friends who would
go straight up there
and try to drag me
along, complaining.
If it was me, I'd rather
look for some other route.
But you can tell all of that
just by looking at this image--
where you can go from there,
not just what kind of a place
it is, but what are the
possible routes you might take.
So these fundamental
problems that we
solve in navigation,
of knowing where am I
and how do I get
from here to there,
include multiple components.
In terms of where am
I, the first piece
is recognizing a
specific place you know.
So you might open your
eyes and say, OK, this
is my living room.
I know this particular place.
But as I just pointed out, even
if the place is unfamiliar,
we can get a sense of what
kind of place this is.
Am I in an urban environment,
a natural environment,
a living room, a bathroom?
Where am I?
A third aspect of
where am I, a third way
that we might answer
that question,
is something about the geometry
of the environment we're in.
So try this right
now-- close your eyes.
OK, now think about how far
the wall is in front of you.
Don't open your eyes, just
think about how far away
it is, how far away the left
wall is and the right wall is.
And how about the
wall behind you?
Don't open your eyes.
How far back is
the wall behind you
from where you are right now?
OK, you can open your eyes.
It's not rocket science.
I just wanted you to intuit that
even though you're presumably
riveted by this lecture, and
thinking only about navigation,
you sort have a kind of
situational awareness
of the spatial layout
of the space you're in.
So you might have a sense
of I'm in a space like this
and I'm over here in it.
And we'll talk more about
that exact kind of awareness
of your position relative
to the spatial layout
of your immediate environment.
It's something that's very
important in navigation.
And another part of
that is you might think,
how would I get out of here?
If I'm seriously
bored by the lecture
or for any other
reason I urgently
need to get out of
here, you probably
know exactly where the
doors are in this space.
It's just part one of those
things that we keep track of.
So those are aspects of
where am I in this place.
What are the things
we need to know
to know how we would get
from here to someplace else?
Well, the simplest way to
navigate to another location
another goal is
called "beaconing."
And this is a case where
you can directly see or hear
your target location.
So you're sailing in the fog.
You can't see a
damn thing, but you
hear the foghorn over
there, and you know
you're sailing to that point.
So you just go toward the
sound, nice and simple.
You don't need any broader
map of anything else.
You just hear it
and head toward it.
Or if you see
this, and your goal
is to get to the green building,
well, there's a green building
and you just head that way.
Now, you're going to have
to go around a little bit
to get around those
obstacles, but you
know where to head because you
can see your target directly.
These are cases
where you don't need
a broader, long-term knowledge
of the whole environment.
If you can see your target,
you just go straight for it.
So that's beaconing,
simplest kind of A to B.
And it requires no
mental map, no kind
of internal model of the whole
world you're navigating in.
But if you can't see the
place you want to go,
then you need some kind of
mental map of the world.
So what do we mean by a
"mental map of the world?"
Well, this idea was
first articulated
in a classic experiment
way back in the 1940s.
So this was actually one of
the original experiments that
launched the cognitive
revolution, when we emerged
from the scourge of behaviorism
to realize that it was actually
OK, and indeed, of the
essence, to talk about what's
going on in the mind.
And a really
influential study that
launched the cognitive
revolution by Tolman
was done on rats.
And it went like
this-- he trained rats.
He put them down in
this area, and they
had to learn that there would
be food out there at the goal.
And so they just have to make
the series of left and right
turns to find the food.
So you train them
on that for a while
till they're really good at it.
And then he put the rats
in this environment.
Now, the environment is
similar, except there's
multiple paths, one that seems
analogous to the old route.
So what are the rats
do in this situation?
They run down here,
they run into a wall,
and they realize, OK,
that's not going to work.
No surprises yet.
But then, the rats
immediately come back out
and they go straight
out that way.
What does that tell you?
What did they learn?
Did they learn a series of
go straight, and then left,
and then right, and then right,
and then go for a long ways?
No.
That wouldn't work over here.
They learned something
much more interesting.
Even though they were only
being trained on this task here,
they learned some much
more interesting thing
about the kind of vector
average of all of those turns.
Everybody get this?
It's really simple
but really deep.
So from this, Tolman
and others started
talking about cognitive
maps, whatever
it is you have to have learned
in a situation like this
so you can abstract
the general direction.
We don't just learn
specific routes
as a series of
stimulus and responses.
So there must be some
kind of map in your head
to be able to do this, and
rats have that, and so do you.
So let's consider this
question right now.
Where am I?
Where are you?
To answer that
question to yourself,
there's something like
this in your head.
And it probably doesn't look
exactly like that in your head,
but there's some version of this
information that's in your head
that you're using
when you answer
the question of where you are.
And you have some way to say
in that map of the world,
I know not just what the
MIT campus looks like
and how it's arranged, but
I know where I am in it.
Now, if you want to know
how to get somewhere else--
like suppose you're
hungry and you
want to go over to the
Stata Cafeteria over there.
What else do you need to
know besides knowledge
of the map of your environment
and where you are in it?
What else do you need to know?
You know you have this map,
you know where you are,
and you know where your goal is.
Now you have to plan
how to get over there.
What else do you need to know?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have to
know which parts are paths
and which parts are buildings.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, exactly--
where can you go in there?
Actually, where can you
physically get through?
Actually, our vector
is right over there,
but you can't go
that way because you
can't go through
that glass, even
though you can see through it.
So knowledge of
physical barriers,
and what's an actual path
and what isn't is crucial.
What else do you need to know?
Suppose we had a
robot in this room,
sitting right here facing the
front of a room like you guys,
and we're programming the
robot on how to get over there.
What are other things we'd
have to tell that robot
to get it to plan how to get
over to the Stata Cafeteria?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Things to watch out
for, like cars and traffic.
NANCY KANWISHER: Absolutely.
We'd have to know about
obstacles, like moving
obstacles, not just fixed ones.
Absolutely.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Initial orientation.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
He has to know which
way he's headed.
You're going to give
this robot instructions
on which way to go.
It matters a whole lot if the
robot is starting like this
or starting like that.
The instructions are different
in the two cases, and likewise
for you guys.
To plan a route, you need to
know which way you're heading.
If you guys have ever
been in Manhattan,
and you come up from the
subway, and you see the street's
going like this, and you
know it's north/south,
and you don't know if you're
heading south or north--
really common thing.
It's not enough to know I'm at
the junction of Fifth and 22nd.
You need to know, am I
facing south or north?
Otherwise you can't figure
out which way to go.
That's called
"heading direction."
We just did all that.
You need to know
your current heading.
You also need to know the
direction of your goal
in order to plan a route to it.
So in this kind of
taxonomy of all the things
you need to know
to navigate, we've
just added that if
you're going to navigate
in your own
environment, you need
to know not just
where you are in it,
but which way you are
facing in that mental map.
And we also talked
about this business
of what routes are
possible from here,
how do we move around
obstacles, where
are the doors, where are the
hazards like cars, et cetera.
A final thing you
need to know is
that even if you have
a good system for all
of these other bits, it's
still possible to get
lost in all kinds of ways.
You lose track, you get
confused, you get lost.
So we also need a way
to reorient ourselves
when we're lost.
And we'll talk a lot about
that in the next lecture.
So this is just common sense.
We're doing a kind
of low-tech version
of Marr computational
theory for navigation.
What are the things that
we would need to know
or that a robot would need to
know to be able to navigate?
Just thinking about the
nature of the problem.
So that's what we need.
What's the neural
basis of all of this?
So I'm going to start right in
with the parahippocampal place
area, not to imply it is
the total neural basis
of this whole thing.
It's just one little piece
of a much bigger puzzle.
But we'll start in there
because it's nice and concrete.
All right, so this story
starts about 20 years ago.
I think I mentioned some
of this in the first class
when I talked about
the story of Bob
and I talked about
Russell Epstein,
who was then my post-doc.
And he was doing nice
behavioral experiments,
and thought it was trashy and
cheap to mess around with brain
imaging.
And he was going
to have none of it
until I said, Russell,
just do one experiment.
Scan subjects looking at scenes.
I know it's kind of
stupid, but just do it.
Then you'll have a
slide for your job talk.
And he scanned subjects
looking at scenes
and looking at objects.
And here is one of those
early subjects, probably me--
I don't remember-- with a
bunch of vertical slices
through the brain, near the
back of the brain down there,
moving forward as
we go up to here.
Everybody oriented?
Sorry, it's not showing up
very well in this lighting,
but there's a little
bilateral region
right in the middle there that
shows a stronger response when
people look at pictures
of scenes than when they
look at pictures of objects.
So we hadn't predicted this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the
pink the eye color?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah, pink is-- all
the colors are--
there's significance
maps or P levels, right.
So pink is higher than blue, but
blue is borderline significant.
So this is kind of dopey.
We didn't actually predict
it for any deep reason.
We hadn't been thinking
about theories of navigation
or anything like that.
It was just one of
those dumb experiments
where we found something
and we followed the data.
So we found this,
and it's, like, OK,
let's try some other subjects.
So here are the first
nine subjects we scanned.
Every single subject had that
kind of signature response
in exactly the same place,
in a part of the brain called
"parahippocampal cortex."
So this is very systematic.
And there's lots of ways to
make progress in science.
One way is to have a
big theory, and use it
to motivate brilliant,
elegantly designed experiments.
And another is you just see
something salient and robust
that you didn't predict,
and you follow your nose,
and try to figure it out.
So that's what we
did in this case.
It's like, OK, what
the hell is that?
So if you think about--
we eventually called it
the "parahippocampal place
area" after a little more work.
If you think about
what we have so far,
we've scanned people looking at
pictures like this and pictures
like that.
And what we've shown is
that little patch of brain
responds a bunch more
to these than those.
So my first question is,
is that a minimal pair?
Tally, is that a minimal pair?
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
I'm about my voice.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry.
Simple, simple.
We're contrasting
this with that.
AUDIENCE: Can you remind
me what a minimal pair is?
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, minimal pair
is this thing we aspire
towards an experimental design,
where we have two
conditions that
are identical except
for one little thing
we're manipulating.
AUDIENCE: I don't really
think it's a minimal pair,
but I'm not really sure.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, I even told you
what we were designing
to manipulate, but--
AUDIENCE: There seems to
be too many differences
between a living room and--
NANCY KANWISHER: It's ludicrous.
I mean, it's a million
differences here.
So we don't know that
we have anything yet.
There's all kinds of
uninteresting accounts
of this systematic activation
in that part of the brain.
So just to list a few
that you've probably
already noticed--
these things have rich,
high-level meaning
and complexity.
So you can think
about living rooms,
or where you might sit, or
somebody's aesthetic, home
design, or there's
all kinds of stuff
to think about there, much more
than just, OK, it's a blender.
So there's just complexity
in every possible way.
There are also lots of
objects present here,
and only a single
object over there.
So maybe that region
just represents objects,
and if you have more objects,
you get a higher signal.
There's another
possibility, and that
is that these images
depict spatial layout,
and that one does not.
So you have some sense of
the walls, and the floor,
and the layout of
the local environment
here that you don't
have over there.
And we could probably list
a million other things It's
a very, very sloppy contrast.
So how are we going to
ask which of these things
might be driving the
response of that region?
Well, a natural thing to do is
just deconstruct the stimuli.
So here's what we did--
this is actually way
back 20 years ago.
There were better methods at the
time, but I didn't know them,
so I actually drove
around Cambridge,
photographed my
friends' apartments,
left the camera on
the same tripod,
moved all the furniture
out of the way,
and photographed
the space again.
Ha, ha.
I know.
And then these will
be probably cut out
with some horrific version
of Adobe Photoshop that
existed 20 years ago.
Anyway, we
deconstructed the scenes
into their component objects
and the bare spatial layout.
Everybody get the logic here?
Just to try to make a big cut
in this hypothesis space of what
might be driving that region.
So what do we predict
that the PPA will--
how strongly will it respond?
Oops, how strongly
will it respond
if these two things are true?
If it's the complexity
or multiplicity
of objects that's
driving it, what do you
predict we will see over there?
We already know you get
a high response here.
What will we get over there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Probably get more
biases to the furniture.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, we'll
respond more to this than that.
Right.
It's really simple-minded.
If instead, it responds
more to the spatial layout,
what do we predict?
Isabel.
AUDIENCE: It's going to respond
to the empty rooms more.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
And that seems like
a weird hypothesis
because these are really boring,
this kind of nothing going on
here.
And there's just lots
of stuff going on here.
I mean, it's not
riveting, but it's
a whole bunch, whole lot
more interesting to look
at these than those.
Believe me, I got scanned
for hours and hours
looking at these things.
And whenever the empty
rooms came on, I was,
like, oh, my god,
I'm just so bored.
There's just nothing here,
whereas here at least there's
stuff.
But that's not what
the PPA thinks.
What the PPA does--
oops, we just did
the localizer--
it responds like this.
This is percent signal
change, a measure
of magnitude of response, to
the full scenes, way down,
less than half the response
to all those objects,
and almost the same response
as the original scene
when all you have is
a bare spatial layout.
Pretty surprising, isn't it?
We were blown away.
We were, like, what?
What?
But can you see how even this
really simple-minded experiment
enables us to just
pretty much rule out
that whole space of hypotheses?
It's not about the
richness, or interest,
or multiplicity of objects.
It's something much
more like spatial layout
because that's kind of all
there is in those empty rooms.
I mean, it could be something
like the texture of wood floors
or something weird like that.
But one's first guess is it's
something about spatial layout.
Does this make sense?
It's just a way to take
a big, sloppy contrast,
and try to formulate
initial hypotheses,
and knock out a whole
big space of hypotheses.
Yes.
Is it Alana?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm sorry, I
might have missed the design.
So people who are
looking at the empty room
would not have the furniture?
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
I skipped over all of that.
We did-- yes, that's true.
We did mush them
all together and one
could worry about that,
that when you see this,
you remember that that's
a version of this.
Absolutely.
And so maybe-- yes, nonetheless,
if what you were doing--
that's absolutely true, but
if what you were doing here
is kind of mentally
recalling this,
then why couldn't you
also do that here?
Maybe you could.
You might argue that this
is more evocative of that
than this is, but it's also got
lots of relevant information.
Yeah, Jimmy.
AUDIENCE: For the
furniture, did you guys
try placing them in the
exact position as the scene
and seeing if that--
NANCY KANWISHER: We
did both versions
for exactly the reasons
you guys are pointing out.
And it didn't make a difference.
Yeah.
Sorry, Cooley.
AUDIENCE: It'd be--
you would transfer
if they were just responding
to the things, like more stuff?
Like in the empty room,
there's more background,
but there's still
more background.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
You're absolutely right.
This is taking us pretty far,
but it's still pretty sloppy.
This stuff goes all the way
up to the edge of the frame,
and here there's
lots of empty space.
Is that what you're getting at?
Absolutely.
I took out those
slides because I
felt I didn't want to spend the
entire lecture doing millions
of controlled
conditions on the PPA.
I thought you'd get bored.
But actually, another
version that we did
was we then took all
of these conditions,
and we chopped them into little
bits and rearranged the bits,
so that you have much
more coverage of stuff
in the chopped-up scenes
than the chopped-up objects.
And in the chopped-up
versions, it
doesn't respond
differently at all.
So it's not the amount of
total spatial coverage.
It's the actual-- something more
like the depiction of space.
Was there a question over there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if there
would be any difference
between looking at images
as 2D or 3D scene, and
actually being there to see
the 3D inside of the scene.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
Totally.
It's a real challenge.
With navigation,
navigation is very
much about being there and
moving around in the space.
And this is just a
pretty rudimentary thing
where you're lying
in the scanner,
and these images are just
flashing, flashing on,
and you're doing
some simple task,
like pressing a button
when consecutive images are
identical.
It's not moving around
in the real world.
You don't think
you're actually there.
But here's where video
games and VR come in
because actually, they produce
a pretty powerful simulation
of knowing your
environment, feeling
you're in a place in it.
And so lots of studies
have used those methods
to give something closer
to the actual experience
of navigation.
So where are we so far?
We've said the PPA seems to
be involved in recognizing
a particular scene.
So this just says it responds
to scenes and something
about spatial layout, maybe.
Does it care about
that particular scene
or do you have to recognize
that particular scene to be
able to use the information?
Now, our subjects mostly didn't
know those particular scenes.
But we wanted to do
a tighter contrast
asking if knowledge of the
particular scene matters.
So what we did was we
took a bunch of pictures
around the MIT campus, and
we took a bunch of pictures
around the Tufts campus.
And we scanned MIT students
looking at MIT pictures
versus Tufts pictures.
And then what else do we do?
AUDIENCE: Get the
Tufts students.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, why?
AUDIENCE: Oh, just to
make sure that it's not
all about that weird
architecture of the set.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
So this is called--
yes, whose weird architecture?
I think ours is weirder.
So it's not just about
the particular scenes
or the particular subjects.
So everybody get how with
that counterbalanced design,
you can really pull out the
essence of familiarity itself,
unconfounded from the
particular images?
So when we did that, we found a
very similar response magnitude
in the PPA for the
Tufts students,
for the familiar and
unfamiliar scenes.
Really didn't make
much difference.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Taking a step
back, so we started off
with the one question
of navigation
and it involving all these
different components.
I just want to place this--
NANCY KANWISHER:
We're getting there.
There won't be like
a perfect answer.
We're not going to end
up with that slide,
with the exact brain region
of each of those things.
We'll get some gisty, vague
senses of what this is.
OK, so this tells
us it's not about--
whatever the PPA is
responding to in a scene,
it's not something that hinges
on knowing that exact scene.
So it can't be something
like, if I was here
and I wanted to get
coffee, what would
my route from this location
be, given my knowledge
of the environment.
Because otherwise, we
wouldn't get this result.
So whatever it
is, it's something
more immediate and perceptual to
do with just seeing this place.
So where are we?
We've said that there's
this region that
responds more to
scenes than objects,
that when all the objects
are removed from the scenes,
the response barely drops.
And its response is
pretty much the same
for familiar and
unfamiliar scenes.
So all of that
suggests that it's
involved in something like
perceiving the shape of space
around you.
Doesn't nail it yet, but
it kind of pushes you
towards that hypothesis.
Yeah, was there a question
here a second ago?
No?
OK.
AUDIENCE: I was talking
about experiment,
but is it accurate
when you look at a map?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh, great question.
Not very much.
Yeah, if you take
pictures of places
from above versus
this kind of view,
you get a response in this
kind of view, but not above.
Yeah, very telling.
OK, so I'm going to skip.
We're not going to do
the 30 other experiments.
We're going to skip to
the general picture, that
here's the PPA in four
subjects in this very
stereotyped location.
And here are some of the
many conditions we've tested.
It's not just abstract
maps like this.
They don't produce
a strong response.
Oh, this is an answer to
Cooley's question way back.
Here's the scrambled-up
scene-- much lower response.
So it's not just
coverage of visual junk.
And it responds pretty strongly
to scenes made out of LEGOs
compared to objects
made out of LEGOs,
and various other silly things.
So all of that seems to suggest
that it's processing something
like the shape or
geometry of space
around you-- visible space in
your immediate environment.
Nonetheless, there's
always pushback.
And there's pushback on multiple
fronts, and there should be.
That's proper science.
So one of the lines of pushback
was this paper by Nasr, et al.
that I didn't assign.
I assigned you the
response to it.
Anyway, what Nasr et al.
Did was scan people looking at
rectilinear things like cubes
and pyramids versus curvilinear,
round-y things like cones,
and spheres.
And what they showed
is the PPA responds
more to the rectilinear
than the curvilinear shapes.
OK, that's the first thing.
And so then, they argue
that in general, scenes
have more rectilinear structure
than curvilinear structure.
And they did a bunch of
math to make that case.
And so they argue that
maybe the apparent scene
selectivity of the PPA is
due to a what of scenes
with rectilinearity?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Confound.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes,
exactly, a confound.
This is exactly what a confound
is-- something else that
covaries with the manipulation
you care about that gives you
an alternative account, namely
it's not scene selectivity.
It's just rectilinearity.
I mean, that might be
interesting to other people,
but it would make it not
very relevant to navigation
and much less interesting
to me, at least.
So that's an
important criticism.
And so then the Bryan et al.
Paper that you guys read
starts from there and says,
let's take that seriously.
Let's find out.
And so you guys should
have read all of this,
but just to remind you, they
have a nice, little 2 by 2
design--
remember we talked
about 2 by 2 designs--
where they manipulate
whether the image has
a lot of rectilinear structure
or less rectilinear structure,
and whether the image
is a place or a face.
And what they find in the PPA
is the same response to these.
And it's higher to the
scenes than the faces,
and rectilinearity didn't
matter for the scenes.
So evidently, even
though it does matter
with these abstract shapes,
in actual scenes and faces,
it doesn't seem
to be doing much.
It's not accounting
for this difference.
Everybody get that?
OK, let's talk about this graph.
Are there main effects
or interactions here?
And what are those main
effects or interactions?
Yes, Cooley.
AUDIENCE: There's
many different scenes.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, of
category, scene versus face.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: What's the first one?
What was the first thing?
In PPA category,
what's the subtype?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, wait,
this here-- these are scenes
and those are faces.
I'm sorry, and this
is the code here.
These are rectilinear
versus curvilinear.
Just one main effect, or
is there an interaction,
or another main effect?
Just one main effect.
These guys are higher
than those guys.
That's it.
So that just tells you
there's nothing else going on
in these data other
than scene selectivity.
Rectilinearity doesn't
interact with or modify scene
selectivity, and it doesn't
have a separate effect.
Nonetheless, as
we've been arguing
with all the whole
Haxby rigmarole,
does the fact that there's no
main effect of rectal linearity
in here mean that the PPA
doesn't have information
about rectilinearity?
No, Josh, why?
AUDIENCE: This little,
tiny moment that could be--
you know, this is not
the right experiment to--
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
This is a big-- well, it's
the right experiment, but not
the right analysis.
It's the big, average
responses are the same,
but maybe the patterns
are different.
That wouldn't directly
engage with this,
but we wanted to know,
was there information
in there about rectilinearity.
So how would we find out?
So this was your
assignment, and I
think most people got it right.
But in case anybody
missed it, we
were zooming in on
this Figure 4 here.
So again, this is just the same
basic design of experiment two.
And now, let's consider
what's going on here.
So you guys read the
paper and you understood
what was going on here.
What's represented in
that cell right there?
What is the point
of this diagram?
What are they doing here?
And what does that cell
mean in that matrix?
You can't understand the
paper without knowing that.
Is it Ali?
No, sorry.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Sheldon.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sheldon,
I've only asked you six times.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So they want to
see whether the activation
patterns can better discriminate
between rectilinearity
of the same category of things
or between categories of things
with the same rectilinearity.
So the first thing I said is
to the left and the second one
is to the right.
And they--
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry,
wait, here and here?
No.
AUDIENCE: Right side.
Yeah, so that part
is discriminating
between rectilinearity,
and that side
is discriminating
between categories.
And they take the
differences of--
well, not the differences,
they take how well
it can distinguish between
each of those categories
and plot them down there.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right, OK.
That's exactly right.
So this is how well it can
discriminate plotted down here,
but based on an analysis
that follows this scheme.
So what does that cell
in there represent,
that dark green cell?
What is the number that's going
to be calculated from the data
corresponding to that cell?
AUDIENCE: Similar piece
of same rectilinearity
and same pattern.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
So just as if you want
to distinguish chairs
from cars or something
else, if you want to know
is there information about
rectilinearity in there,
you take these two
cases which are
the same in rectilinearity--
both high rectilinear, both low
rectilinear for run
one and run two--
and that's the correlation
between run one
and run two for those cells.
That's the within
rectilinearity case.
And if there's information
about rectilinearity,
the prediction is those
within correlations
are higher than the
between correlations,
just as we argued a bit
back with beaches and cities
and everything else--
same argument.
This is just presenting the
data in terms of run one
and run two, and which cells do
we grab to do this computation.
So each of the cells in
there-- for each of the cells,
we're going to calculate
an r value of how
similar those patterns are.
A pattern for rectilinear
scenes in run two,
a pattern for rectilinear
scenes in run one-- this cell
is a correlation between
those two patterns.
How stable is that pattern
across repeated measures?
All right, so that's
what that r value is.
The two darker blue squares here
are the r values for stimuli
that differ in rectilinearity.
And remember that the essence
of the Haxby-style pattern
analysis is to see if
the within correlations
are higher than the
between correlations.
In this case, the
within correlations
are within rectilinearity
versus between rectilinearity.
And so then they calculate all
those correlation differences
and they plot them as
discrimination abilities.
And so what this is showing
us here is that actually,
the PPA doesn't
have any information
in its pattern of response
about the rectilinearity
of the scene.
However, if we
take the same data,
and now choose within category
versus between category,
ignoring rectilinearity,
and we get
the same kind of selectivity
correlation difference within
versus between for
category, there's
heaps of information
about category.
Does that make sense?
Again, if you're fuzzy about
this, look back on that slide.
I have lots of suggestions for
how to unfuzzy yourself on it.
So interim summary-- PPA
responds more to scenes
than objects.
It seems to like spatial
layout in particular.
It does respond more
to boxes than circles,
but that rectilinearity
bias can't
account for scene selectivity.
That's all very nice, but
what is a whole other kind
of fundamental
question we haven't yet
asked about the PPA?
So we've been messing
around with functional MRI,
measuring magnitudes
of response,
trying to test these kind of
vague or general hypotheses
about what it might
be responding to.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Causation.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes,
what particular causation?
AUDIENCE: I guess like
how the scenes, like
with how the PPA with what role
it plays in the person being
seen.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
Again, we can test the causal
role of a stimulus on the PPA,
all of the stuff I
talked about did that.
Manipulate the stimulus,
find different PPA responses.
But what we haven't
done yet is ask,
what is the causal relationship,
if any, between activity
and the PPA and perception
of scenes or navigation?
So far, this is all
just suggestive.
We have no causal
evidence for its role
in navigation or perception.
All right, so let's get some.
I'll show you a few examples.
So one, as, you guys
have learned by now
is these rare
cases where there's
direct electrical
stimulation of a region,
and there's one patient
in whom this is reported.
This patient again, is being
mapped out before neurosurgery.
They did functional MRI
in the patient first.
This is his functional
MRI response to, I think,
houses versus objects.
Houses are not as
strong an activator
as scenes for the PPA,
but they're pretty good.
PPA responds much more to
houses than other objects.
And so that's a nice
activation map showing the PPA.
And those little circles are
where the electrodes are,
little, black circles.
So they know they're in the PPA
because they did functional MRI
first to localize that region.
Now those electrodes
are sitting there.
And so first thing
we do is record--
or first thing they did--
is record responses.
They flash up a bunch of
different kind of images,
and they measure the
response in those electrodes.
And so what you see
is in those electrodes
right over there, 1, 2, 3,
that correspond to the PPA,
you see a higher
response to house images
than to any of the other images.
And you see the time course
here over a few seconds.
Everybody clear?
This is not causal evidence yet.
It's just amazing, direct
intracranial recordings
from the PPA--
I think the only time
this was ever done,
because it's pretty rare to
have the electrodes right there
in a patient who's willing to
look at your silly pictures,
and all of that.
But now, what happens
when they stimulate there?
So let's look at what
happens when they stimulate
on these sites 4 and 3 that are
off to the side of the scene
selectivity.
And this is just a dialogue.
We don't have a
video, unfortunately.
The videos are more
fun, but this is just
a dialogue between the
neurologist and the patient.
And the neurologist electrically
stimulates that region
and says, did you
see anything there?
Patient says, I don't know.
I started feeling something.
I don't know, it's
probably just me.
No, it's not you.
And then they stimulate again.
Anything there?
No.
Anything here?
So that's right next to
the side of the scene
selective electrodes, right next
door, a few millimeters away.
Then, they move their
stimulator over here.
They don't move
anything, they just
control where they're
going to stimulate.
Patient, of course, has no idea.
Neurologist says,
"Anything here?
Do you see anything,
feel anything?"
Patient says, "Yeah,
I feel like--"
he looks perplexed,
puts hand to forehead--
"I feel like I saw
some other site.
We were at the train station."
Neurologist cleverly
says, "So it
feels like you're
at a train station?"
Patient says, "Yeah,
outside the train station."
Neurologist-- "Let me know if
you get any sensation like that
again."
Stimulates.
"Do you feel anything here?"
"No."
And then he does it again.
Did you see the
train station or did
it feel like you were
at the train station?
Patient, "I saw it."
These are very sparse, precious
data, but that's so telling.
It's not that he knew he was at
the train station abstractly.
He saw it.
So then, they
stimulate again, right
on those
scene-selective regions.
Patient says again, "I saw
almost like, I don't know,
like I saw--
it was very brief."
Neurologist says, "I'm going to
show it to you one more time."
Really what he
means is, I'm going
to stimulate you in the
same place one more time.
"See if you can
describe it any further.
And to give you one last
time, what do you think?"
"I don't really know
what to make of it,
but I saw, like,
another staircase.
The rest I couldn't make out,
but I saw a closet space,
but not this one."
He points to a closet
door in the room.
"That one was stuffed
and it was blue."
"Have you seen it before,"
neurologist, "Have you
seen it before at some point
in your life, you think?"
"Yeah, I mean when I
saw the train station."
"Train station you've been at?"
"Yeah."
Et cetera, et cetera.
So it's not a lot of data.
But it's very compelling.
What is the patient describing?
Places he's in that
he sees, and then he
describes this closet
space and its colors.
Interestingly,
colored regions are
right next to scene regions,
so that's kind of cool, too.
So it's causal evidence.
It's sparse.
Ideally, we'd like more in
science, but it's pretty cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At this point,
the patient is just
staring at a blank wall?
NANCY KANWISHER: I actually
forget in the paper.
I've got to go look that up.
I forget exactly what the
patient was doing, whether--
I think he's just in
the room looking out.
Usually, they don't control
it that much because it's
done for clinical
reasons, and the patient
is in their hospital bed,
and they're just stimulating.
So he's probably just looking
out at the space he's in.
In fact, he must have
been because at one point,
he says, "The closet, not
like that one over there."
So if he was staring
at a blank thing,
he was also looking
out at his room.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: This may be
a little bit off topic.
You said that the region
for color perception
is very close to
this, it seems like.
Is there any relationship
between functional proximity
and--
NANCY KANWISHER: That's
a great question.
Nobody in the field
has an answer to this.
People often make hay about
the proximity of two regions,
like there's some deep
link because this thing is
next to that thing.
The body selective region is
right next to, and in fact
slightly overlapping with, area
MT that responds to motion.
It's like, bodies move.
Well, faces move
and cars move, too.
So I don't know.
It's tantalizing.
It feels like it ought
to mean something.
And people often
talk as if it does.
And maybe it does,
but nobody's really
put their finger on what
exactly it would mean.
But it's useful.
So when Rosa Lafer-Sousa who
you met in the color demo,
and I showed that in
humans, you get face, color,
and place regions right next to
each other in that order, that
was really cool because
Rosa had previously
shown that in monkeys, the
monkey brain it goes face,
color, place in
exactly the same order.
And so we thought that's
really interesting.
That suggests common
inheritance because that's
so weird and arbitrary.
Why would it be the same?
So it can be useful in
ways like that, at least.
So we just went
through all of this.
So how does this go beyond what
we knew from functional MRI?
I'm insulting your intelligence.
You know the answer to this.
It goes beyond it
because it tells you--
it implies that
there's a causal role
of that region in
place perception,
some aspect of seeing a place.
Now, all of this
about the PPA I just
started in there because
it's nice, and concrete,
and easy to think about.
But no complex mental
process happens
in just one brain region.
Nothing is ever like that.
And likewise, scene
perception and navigation
is part of a much
broader set of regions.
So if you do a contrast,
scan people looking
at scenes versus objects, you
see not just the PPA in here.
Again, this is a
folded-up brain,
and this is the mathematically
unfolded version
so you can see the whole cortex.
Dark bits are the bits that
used to be inside a sulcus
until it was
mathematically unfolded.
So there's the PPA kind of
hiding up in that sulcus.
And when you unfold it, you see
this nice, big, huge region.
But you also see all
these other regions.
Now there's a bunch of
terminology and don't panic.
I don't think you should
memorize everything
about each region.
You should know that there's
multiple scene regions.
You should know some
of the kinds of ways
you tease apart the functions,
and some of the functions
that have been tested,
and how they're tested.
But you don't need to
memorize every last detail.
Because it's going to
get a little hairy.
So here's a second
scene region right
there called retrosplenial
cortex or RSC.
And actually,
Russell Epstein and I
saw that activation in
the very first experiments
we did in the
1990s, but we really
didn't know what we
were doing back then.
And we knew that this is right
near the calcarine sulcus.
Remind me, what happens
in the calcarine sulcus?
What functional region lives
It's just a weird,
little fact, but it's
kind of an important one
that we mentioned weeks ago.
V1, primary visual cortex--
that's where primary
visual cortex lives.
And remember,
primary visual cortex
has a map of retinotopic
space, with next door bits
of primary visual
cortex responding
to next door bits of space.
And in fact, that
map has the center
of gaze out here and
the periphery out there.
So when Russell and I
first saw that activation,
we had the same worry that
Cooley mentioned a while back.
And that is the scenes
are sticking out.
There's stuff everywhere.
The objects, there isn't
that much sticking out.
And we thought, oh, that's just
peripheral retinotopic cortex.
But it's not.
It's right next to there and
it's a totally different thing.
And it turns out to be
extremely interesting.
You don't need to know all that.
It's just silly, little history.
There's a third region up there
that's on the outer surface
out there that used to be called
TOS and is now called OPA.
I'm sorry about that.
You don't need to remember this.
Know that there are at
least three regions.
But TOS slash OPA is
interesting because there's
a method we can apply to it that
we can't apply to the others.
What would that method be?
AUDIENCE: TMS.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, TMS--
it's right out on the surface.
You just stick the coil
there and go "zap."
So of course, we've
done a lot of that.
Can't get the coil
into the PPA or RSC.
It's too medial.
And there's another
region that we'll
talk about more next time
called the hippocampus.
You saw the hippocampus when
Ann Graybiel spent all that time
digging in the
temporal lobe to find
that bumpy, little,
dentate gyrus,
approximately right in there.
And so all of these--
and probably other
regions, but these
are the core elements of
the scene selective regions
that are implicated in
different aspects of navigation.
So when you have
multiple regions
that seem to be part of a
system, that's an opportunity.
Because now we have
the possibility
that maybe we could figure
out different functions
for different regions.
And then maybe that would really
tell us more than just scenes
and navigation, end of story.
It's kind of rudimentary.
It would be nice if different
aspects of the navigation story
engage different
parts of the system.
So really what we
want to know is,
how does each of these regions
help us navigate and see
scenes.
And I'm not going to
answer that fully.
The field is still trying
to understand all of this,
but I'll give you a few
tantalizing little snippets.
So let's take retrosplenial
cortex right here.
So this is first the
response of the PPA
right there, and retrosplenial
cortex, which is just
behind it.
This is just its mean response
to a bunch of different kinds
of stimuli, showing
you that it likes
landscapes and cityscapes,
scenes, more than a bunch
of other categories of objects.
And that's true of
both the PPA and RSC.
No surprises here-- they're
both somewhat scene selective.
But then in a whole
bunch of other studies
summarized in this graph
here, Russell Epstein
and his colleagues had subjects
engage in different tasks
while they were
looking at scenes.
In some tasks, they had
to say where they were.
He's at UPenn, and he
showed his subjects
pictures of the UPenn campus.
And they had to answer
all kinds of questions
about what part of
campus they were,
where they were on campus,
and also about which way they
were facing given the view of
the campus they were looking
at.
Then he also showed
people familiar scenes
and unfamiliar scenes, much like
we did with our Tufts study.
And he had object controls.
And you can see the PPA
doesn't care about any of that,
doesn't care, really, if
they're familiar or unfamiliar,
doesn't care what task
you're doing on the scene.
You're looking at a
scene, it's just going.
So we didn't really tease
apart functions there.
But RSC responds differently
in these conditions.
It's engaged in both
the location task
and the orientation task.
It responds
substantially more when
you look at images of a familiar
place than an unfamiliar place.
So this is the first time we've
seen that in the same network.
And so now, think
about all the things
you can do when you're looking
at a picture of a scene
and you know that place.
You have memories of
having been there.
You can think about
what you might
do if you were there,
how you would get
from there to someplace else.
All of those things
are possible things
that might be driving RSC.
Another thing that
might be driving RSC
is that if you're looking at
a picture of a familiar place,
you orient yourself with respect
to the broader environment
that that view is part of.
So what I showed you that
picture of the front of Stata,
you immediately imagine,
I'm out on Vassar Street
facing that way, roughly
northwest, I think.
If you look at a
picture of a scene
and you don't know
that scene, it
doesn't tell you anything
about your broader heading
in the broader world.
So all of those are things
that the RSC, its function
seems to depend on
knowing that place.
Perhaps the most
telling case comes
from a patient who had damage
in retrosplenial cortex.
And the description
in the paper of this
says that this patient
could recognize
buildings and the
landmarks, and therefore,
understand where he was.
So lots is intact--
can recognize scenes
and know where he is.
But the landmarks he
recognized did not
provoke directional information
about any other places
with respect to those landmarks.
So this person can
look at a picture
and say, yeah, I
know that place.
That's the front of my house.
But then if you say, in
which direction is a coffee
shop two blocks
away, he doesn't know
which way it is from there.
So this should sound familiar.
This is my guess of the bit that
my friend Bob got messed up.
Yeah.
This is exactly
his description--
he could recognize
places, but it
wouldn't tell him how to get
from there to somewhere else.
And so the best current guess
about retrosplenial cortex
is that it's involved in
anchoring where you are.
You have this mental map of the
world, and you have a scene,
and you're trying to
put them together.
Given that I see this,
where am I on the map,
and which way am I
heading in that map?
Again, think about the problem
you face when you emerge
from the subway in Manhattan.
You look around.
Where am I, and which
way am I heading?
That's what you need
retrosplenial cortex for.
How about this TOS thing?
There's lots of studies of it.
I'll give you just
one little offering.
So this is a causal
investigation
because as we discussed, the TOS
is out on the lateral surface.
So we can zap it.
And so of course, we do.
And so in this
study, we were asking
whether TOS is involved in
perceiving the structure
of space around you.
So we took scenes like
this from CAD programs,
and we just varied
them slightly.
So for example, the position
of this wall moves around,
the aspect ratio, the height
of the ceiling moves around,
and we make this subtle morph
space of different versions
of this image.
And then for control condition,
we do the same with faces.
We morph between this
guy and that guy,
and make a whole
spectrum in between.
And then in the task, what
we do is here's one trial.
One of the scenes or
faces comes on briefly,
and then shortly thereafter,
you get a choice of two,
and you have to say which
of these matches that one.
And then what we do
is we zap people right
after we present this stimulus.
And so the idea is
this is as close
as we can get to a pretty
pure perceptual task.
How well can you see the
shape of that environment
or the shape of that face?
You don't have to remember it
for more than a few hundred
milliseconds.
So it's really more of a
perception task than a memory
task.
And what we measure
is, we actually
muck with how different these
two images are in each trial,
and measure how
far apart they have
to be in morph space for
you to be about 75% correct.
That's the standard
psychophysical measure.
The details don't matter.
But our dependent measure is,
how different do the stimuli
have to be for you
to discriminate them
as a function of whether you're
getting zapped in TOS or not.
And so here are the data.
So let's take the
case where you're
doing the scene task here.
What this threshold
is, is again,
how different the
stimuli need to be
for you to discriminate them.
So the higher the bar,
the worse performance.
They have to be really different
or you can't tell them apart.
And so what you
see is when you zap
OPA, that lateral
scene selective region,
discrimination
threshold goes up a bit.
That means you get worse
at the discrimination.
The stimuli need to
be more different.
Compared to zapping
the top of your head--
remember, you always
want a control condition,
and there's no perfect
control condition
because it feels differently to
be zapped in different places.
But getting zapped up here is
a better than nothing control.
And then here's the
occipital face area.
That's the lateral face region
we talked about before when
I showed you another TMS study.
Basically, whenever
there's anything lateral,
we zap it because we can.
And see, it's not affected here.
Zapping the occipital face area
does not mess up your ability
to discriminate the scenes.
However, in the face task,
we see the opposite pattern.
For the face task, zapping
the occipital place area
doesn't do anything compared to
zapping the top of your head,
but zapping the face area does.
This is a double dissociation.
If we just had the scene task,
it would be like, yeah, maybe.
Who knows.
Maybe, who knows why.
But it's not very strong.
But when you have
these opposite things,
then we really have much
more strong evidence
that these two regions
have different functions
from each other.
Everybody get that this
is a double dissociation,
in the same sense of when you
have one patient with damage
in one location and
another patient with damage
in another location
and they have
opposite patterns of deficit,
then we're really in business.
Then we can draw
strong inferences.
So we just said all of that.
So that's just a little snippet.
These and other data suggest
that that region is strongly
active when you look
at scenes, and it
seems to be involved in
something like perceiving--
just directly online
perceiving the structure
of the space in front of you.
So we already did
retrosplenial cortex.
And next time, we'll talk
about the hippocampus in there,
and its role in the
whole navigation thing.
Now, since I have ended early--
a rare event--
I actually put together a whole
other piece of this lecture,
and I thought, no, don't always
have a part you don't get to.
But then it turns
out we do get to it.
We're going to go
over this more later,
but we're going to start with
this business right here.
So anybody have questions
about this stuff so far?
OK, so I've spent a
lot of time talking
about multiple voxel pattern
analysis, because it's
the only method I've mentioned
so far that enables us to go
beyond the business of
saying how strongly do
the neurons fire in
this region to the more
interesting question of what
information is contained
in this region.
But I also ended
the last lecture
with this kind of
depressive note--
that you can't see much with
MVPA applied to face patches,
even when we know there's
information in there
with electrophysiology data.
Remember, I showed
you that monkey
study where they tried MVPA
in the face patches in monkeys
and they couldn't kind
of read out a damn thing.
And then they try MVPA on
individual neural responses
of the same region,
and they can read out
all kinds of information.
And that tells you the
information is there
and we just can't
always see it with MVPA.
Now today, you've seen
cases where can see stuff
with MVPA in the scene region.
So sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't.
And when it doesn't
work, we're left
in this unsatisfying
situation that we
don't know if the
information isn't there
or if the neurons are
just so scrambled together
that we can't see the
different patterns.
So bottom line, we
need another method.
MVPA is a whole lot
better than nothing,
but we want to be
able to ask, is there
information present in
this region even when we
think the relevant neurons are
all spatially intermingled?
So let me just do a
little bit of this
and then we'll continue later.
So goal-- this new method
is called "event-related
functional MRI adaptation."
And we use it when
we want to know
if neural populations
in a particular region
can discriminate between two
stimuli, two stimulus classes.
So for example, do
neurons in the FFA
distinguish between this
image and that image?
So if we want to
know that, we could
measure the functional
MRI response in the FFA
and find this would be an
event-related response,
similar responses to the two.
And as I just
mentioned, that wouldn't
mean that there isn't
information in the FFA
that discriminates that.
It just says they have
the same mean response.
Everybody get that?
Now, if we zoom in, and think
about what might neurons
be doing, it's still
possible-- even
with the same mean
response-- that neurons
could be organized like this,
with some of them responding
only to this image and some
of them responding only
to that image.
But it's also possible
that all of the neurons
respond equally to both.
And we kind of
desperately need to know--
I mean, not in this case.
This is a toy
example, obviously.
But we often, when we're
trying to understand
a region of the brain, we
need to know which situation
we're in.
So that neural population can
discriminate these two and that
one can't.
How are we going to
tell which is true?
Well, we talked before
about multiple voxel pattern
analysis, but as I
just said, it only
works when the neurons
are spatially clustered
on the scale of voxels.
So imagine you have
these situations here.
This is getting more and
more of a toy example,
but just to give you the idea.
Suppose where those neural
populations land with respect
to voxels is like this.
So if each of these is a
voxel in the brain, a little,
say, 2 by 2 by 3
millimeter chunk of brain
that we're getting
an MRI signal from,
if you have the different
neural populations
spatially segregated
enough that they mostly
land in different voxels,
then MVPA might work here.
Is that intuitive?
Do you guys all see that?
Then we'd get a different
pattern in these voxels
if we're looking at those
two different images.
But even if we have
the situation here,
which is kind of
informationally the same,
if they're spatially
scrambled so that they're
in roughly equal proportion in
each voxel, MVPA won't work.
Does that make sense?
And so that's when we need this
other method called "functional
MRI adaptation."
Make sense?
I'm going to go one
minute over probably.
So the point of
functional MRI adaptation
is it can work even when
there's no spatial clustering
of the relevant
neural populations
on the scale of voxels.
So let me go through
it quickly and we'll
come back to it later.
So here's how it goes--
the basic idea is,
any measure that's
sensitive to the sameness versus
difference between two stimuli
can reveal what that system
takes to be same or different.
So for example, if a
brain region discriminates
between two similar stimuli
like these, then if we measure
the functional MRI
response in that region
to same versus
different trials--
so this would be
a different trial.
You present Trump and then
the chimp back to back.
That's one trial, compared
to a same trial, chimp
and then chimp.
And of course, we
counterbalance everything,
so we also do chimp and then
Trump in another different case
and then Trump and then
Trump in another same case.
If we find that the
neural response is higher
when the two stimuli are
different than when they're
same, then we know
that that region
has neurons that respond
differentially to the two.
So remember, we
started with a case
where the mean
response is the same
to this image and this image
if you just measure them alone.
But now we want to
know, do we really
have neurons that
respond differentially?
So we're using the
fact that neurons
are like people and muscles.
If you keep doing the same
thing to them, they get bored.
Been there, done that.
So you present
this back to back.
You get a lower response than if
you present this and then this.
That's called "functional
MRI adaptation."
It's like that
waterfall MT adaptation
we talked about before, but just
crammed into a fine time scale.
And so then if you do that, you
can ask what a region thinks
is the same.
So then, we could ask, what
about these two images?
Does it think
those are the same?
And if we find a response like
that, what have we learned?
So if these two
respond like that,
what have we learned
about a region that shows?
This is all fake
data, obviously,
but if we saw that,
what have we learned?
And then I'll let
you go, as soon as I
get a nice answer to this.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if it's the
same between two pictures
of the same stimuli, that
means that it's activated.
It can discriminate.
But if the yellow is at
the same degree as the red,
it would just be the brain
reacting to different pictures.
NANCY KANWISHER: You
totally get that.
It's probably right,
and you totally get it.
Key point-- just because I
don't want to torture you guys
and go way over-- but key point
is, it's the same response is
the lower response.
We tell that with this case, and
we actually give it a same one.
So same is lower than different.
That's just how
this method works.
Then we're basically
asking, does
that count as the same
to this brain region?
And we're finding, yes, it does.
That tells us that
those neurons are
invariant to all
kinds of things--
viewpoint, facial
expression, when he last
dyed his hair, who the hell
knows, all these other things.
So we'll talk more about this.
But the idea is, now we have
another method in addition
to MVPA that can start to tell
us what neurons are actually
discriminating.
OK, sorry to go over.